[Music]
we had to spend quite some time waiting
but on december 5th 2021 the first
trailer for spider-man across the
spider-verse was finally released this
is the second part of into the
spider-verse starring miles morales and
spider-gwen not only was the first part
from 2018 well received by die-hard
comic fans but it also convinced critics
internationally it was not for nothing
that he won the oscar for best animated
film next year the second part is to be
shown in theaters with a planned release
date of june 2nd the first trailer made
the hearts of fans leave for joy because
as expected gwen also plays a major role
again that's not all however based on
the footage shown which is actually more
of a longer scene from the film and
other sources we can already draw some
interesting conclusions about the movie
for you guys we have dealt with a
possible storyline and all further
aspects that will be relevant for the
film so stay tuned
considering that the first part had a
lot to offer and that it's been a while
we will briefly summarize the most
important points if you haven't seen it
yet and don't want any spoilers you
should hurry up and skip to the next
part young miles morales was bitten by a
radioactive spider this happens in the
same brooklyn where peter parker from
the famous spiderman movies of 2002
fights evil as the friendly neighborhood
spider when he suddenly acquires
abilities he returns to the place where
he was bitten there he finds spiderman
fighting kingping among other villains
the gangster boss opens her portal to
other universes trying to get his dead
family back but fails in doing so
nevertheless he manages to kill peter as
new york mourns and mild stands at
peter's grave an older version of peter
unexpectedly shows up shortly after
spider-gwen spider-man hua and
spider-ham also appear it quickly turns
out that all the spideys were launched
into miles universe from other universes
by kingpin's machine in spite of all
warnings the gangster boss wants to
switch on the machine again which will
lead to the destruction of the whole
city in the final battle the spidey
succeed in defeating kingpin and his
gang of villains united everyone returns
to the universes and miles morales
becomes the new friendly neighborhood
spider in new york
so what sort of multiverse spiderman or
spider women will we meet in the sequel
thanks to the post credits scene and the
first trailer we already know a little
bit of information about the spideys who
will be providing law and order in the
upcoming movie
as expected miles morales remains the
protagonist of the film the young
teenager eventually became the new
spider-man of the city after his victory
over kingpin besides we are all curious
to see how the relationship with his
father will evolve after they finally
managed to get together at the end of
the last film
as has already been confirmed gwen stacy
will also be back after all spider-gwen
ended up befriending miles and it is
clearly hard for her to say her goodbyes
and return to a universe
juan gets female support from jessica
drew who most of you probably know as
spider woman as a young girl she was
seriously ill prompting her father to
develop his spider serum to cure her
however upon injecting it into her she
developed superpowers similar to miles
morales just like him she can send out
an electric shock also known as venom
blast in the comics she first joined
hydra before joining shield whether that
will also be the casing across the
spider verse is yet unclear
we were already introduced to a newcomer
for the second part in the post-credits
scene of the first movie then we see
miguel o'hara also known as spider-man
2099 sad spider-man as you can guess is
from the year 2099 where the world is
ruled by corporations new york is
divided into a rich and poor district
and the time of heroes is long gone
o'hara tries to become spider-man
through the use of genetic manipulation
which he ultimately succeeds in doing
unlike his predecessors he no longer
needs web shooters as he can shoot
threats himself however he lacks the
spider sense of the other spider-man in
return he is able to paralyze his
opponents by biting them
another newcomer is takoya yamashiro
also known as the japanese spider-man
sure we already had an anime or manga
spot in the first movie nevertheless
takoya will be based more on the
original the tokyo boy is an
enthusiastic motocross racer until he's
injected with a serum that alters his
genes similar to miguel o'hara his
powers are comparable to those of peter
parker the only real difference is that
his great weakness is the extreme cold
similar to that of real spiders so far
nothing is known about possible
antagonists which of course leaves
plenty of room for creativity when it
comes to the plot of the second part
thanks to the trailer there's no need
for us to completely guess what the
second part might be about in addition
comics and other hollywood sources also
provide us with clues as to what will
happen next with our spider heroes what
will be clear is that there will be a
love affair between miles and gwen
actually this was already planned to
happen in the first part but then it was
cut out in addition spider woman's
appearance will also introduce a planned
spin-off it is supposed to be about gwen
stacy jessica drew and cindy moon also
called silk
diving into the eventual plot let's
briefly talk about the post-credits
scene once more there a jump is made
into the universe of miguel o'hara you
see a researcher talking about how the
multiverse nearly collapsed the woman
hands spidey a bracelet that can be used
to jump purposefully through the
multiverse this is how miguel heads to
the year 1967 to bring the famous comic
book and meme spider-man into his
reality
as one can see in the trailer the main
characters are a lot older than in the
first movie and are now going to college
that makes it all the more unpleasant
for miles to have gwen show up in his
child's room when he pays him an
impromptu visit from the multiverse they
rapidly travel through the web of
destiny in multiple realities that would
at least mean explanation for the
hexagonal portals that can be seen in
one reality they seem to have arrived in
the year 2099 there miles gets attacked
rather quickly by miguel o'hara better
known as spiderman 2099 who in turn
travels with him through several
realities that like the spideys in the
first part differ in their drawing style
so if we jump to a conclusion from the
images we've already seen the plot could
be as follows spider-man 2099 already
traveled through the multiverse to look
for other spideys to assist him his
reality may be in such danger that he
would not be able to make it on his own
all the whole multiverse might be about
to fall apart again the fact that he
attacked miles upon entering his reality
is not something we would give much
emphasis to he will probably quickly
realize that the miles is not an enemy
in this future superheroes do not
actually play a role anymore and only
live in the stories from better days by
the time this misunderstanding is
resolved spider-man 2099 will already
have the support of at least three more
heroes mild gwen and the already
confirmed jessica drew or spider-woman
there o'hara usually fights against
doctor doom or venom since venom 2 let
there be carnage has just started
streaming we can very well imagine
doctor doom with kingpin's attempt to
mess around in the multiverse the latter
could develop plants of his own to
harness the power of different universes
for himself that would definitely make
him one of the most threatening
opponents because after all even without
that power dr doom is one of the most
powerful villains either way purposeful
travel between universes will surely
play a big part this is done through the
aforementioned web of destiny at least
that's how the heroes travel in the
comics perhaps this will also allow them
to stay longer in another universe which
would certainly benefit the romans
between miles and gwen finally one last
interesting piece of information can be
taken from the end of the trailer the
official title of the film is given the
edition part one and the likelihood we
can expect an epic story that will be
told in several parts but for now we are
eagerly awaiting the first follow-up we
will know more as soon as the next
trailer comes out at the latest in june
2023 when the film hits theaters
so there you have it all facts and
theories about spider-man across the
spider-verse what do you think do you
have any other suggestions on how the
movie could turn out feel free to let us
know in the comments below we are
definitely looking forward to learning
more about miles morales and the
spider-verse
see you next time
[Music]
you